[Music]
many Americans are struggling with the
consequences of stay-at-home orders
during this pandemic calls to the
government's mental health hotline were
up nearly 900 percent in the month of
March from the same month last year and
we're also seeing a rise in both
antidepressant and anti-anxiety
prescriptions CBS News mental health
contributor that's dr. su pharma joins
us to discuss su I can't believe that
I'm seeing you today of all days just
yesterday a friend sent me a number of a
psychiatrist and said Gayle you need to
make a call and I was a little taken
aback by that because I don't think what
I'm experiencing is any more than
anybody else so how do you know when
it's time to seek help asking for a
friend
Calvin yes Gayle what a great question
and you know the reality is that we are
all experiencing a wave of emotions that
might change from moment to moment and I
say to people that you might feel sad
one moment and might feel thankful
another moment and the reality is is
that grief and gratitude can coexist it
doesn't mean that there's something
wrong with you but how do we know when
it's a problem is when it starts to
interfere with your daily life so is a
low mood unshakable do your daily tasks
feel insurmountable and are the things
that were once fun to you no longer
pleasurable and to me that means that
this is an issue and also I ask people
about their sleep why because I think
that sleep is a window into your mental
health I think that a lot of people may
not experiencing anxiety or depression
during the day they may say I'm busy I'm
distracted I've got people to take care
of I've got things to do but how are you
sleeping not well I haven't slept in two
months doc that's what I'm hearing so I
think that we had problems sleeping even
before the average person might have
about thirty four percent of the time
have some sort of acute insomnia about
two-thirds or three-fourths of the time
it dissipates by itself but really we
want to see how people are sleeping
because to me that might be a better
hallmark than just asking them how
they're feeling well at what point does
staying at home take a toll on your
mental health it doesn't seem to me that
it's a one-size-fits-all on this
question no it really varies from person
to person and there was an interesting
Lancet review that came out at the end
of February that looked at
twenty four studies from ten countries
who had experienced different outbreaks
deadly outbreaks and one study from
Canada found that even ten days was
enough to increase the risk for having
post-traumatic stress disorder anger and
avoidance but really it's going to
depend on a variety of factors do you
have a history of mental illness to
begin with and then do you feel as if
you didn't get adequate information
about the pandemic if you were dealing
with one did you not have adequate
supplies were there financial losses so
all of this compounds away and will make
the decision as to how many days but you
know it really does vary from person to
person based on pre-existing conditions
including lack of social support well
Toni had a great tease when he was
talking about your appearance coming up
he said that you would have four steps
to help us with our mental health what
are they can you give us a boom
boom-boom-boom
yes so the four M's of mental health as
I call it is movement meaningful
engagement mastery and mindfulness and
these are just quick things that you can
do ten or fifteen minutes I'm a big
believer and if you can get outside
brisk walk wearing a mask social
distancing get adequate sunlight in the
daytime and this shuts off the melatonin
it tells that your brain that it's ready
for the day and believe it or not it
actually helps you sleep at night when
it comes to mindfulness spend five or
ten minutes doing deep breathing there
are tons of apps out there calm
headspace do whatever feels good for you
progressive muscle relaxation is one of
them when it comes to meaningful
engagement you have to connect with
people on any level on a deeper level on
a superficial level these days I can't
get to tell you how excited I get to go
to the grocery store once a week so that
I can see other people outside of my
family and those those little micro
conversations are really key but also
call text FaceTime do whatever you can
to have those deeper more vulnerable
conversations and then mastery do
something that feels good you don't have
to be a master to be experiencing
mastery and that's just something
creative a state of flow and the
difference between anxiety and
depression is anxiety is rumination or
worry about the future
a long
irritability trouble sleeping trouble
concentrating having physiological
reactions heart racing increased blood
pressure and it's very much focused
about the future what if depression on
the other hand often is about the past
and rumination and regret and feelings
of sadness worthlessness hopelessness
along with sleep problems and difficulty
concentrating and appetite a lot of
times anxiety and depression go
hand-in-hand
and obviously the medications what's
interesting is that antidepressants also
work for anxiety so you know it's very
important to talk to your doctor to
figure out which one you have and which
medication might be better because a lot
of the antidepressants are actually FDA
approved for anxiety medications alright
dr. sue Varma very good to see you
giving us a lot to think about really
appreciate that if you or someone you
know thank you if someone if you or
someone you know is seeking mental
health resources you can call the
national hotline there is a number for
you the National Alliance on Mental
Illness the helpline is one eight
hundred nine five Oh Nami one eight
hundred nine five Oh Nami or one eight
hundred nine five Oh 62 64 I think I
like it better that one that way or in a
crisis you can text them at 741 741